[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt endlich ist es soweit die sonne ist
da die ersten sonnenstunden kommen schon
und bei uns in waghäusel wird auch
teilweise schon richtig warm also so an
die 20 bis 24 grad
natürlich fröstelt nachts noch ein
bisschen aber wir wollen einfach an die
frische luft wir wollen raus in unseren
garten und machen deswegen jetzt unseren
garten wieder sommerfest
[Musik]
das winterfest video habt ihr bereits
gesehen das haus habe ich auch schon auf
vordermann gebracht das heißt drinnen
ist alles picobello geputzt der
frühjahrsputz den habe ich schon hinter
mich gebracht jetzt ist der garten dran
damit wirklich jede stunde jede sekunde
und jede minute im garten verbringen
können ich muss mich jetzt zuerst einmal
um unsere möbel kümmern
die stehen nämlich hier und danach wird
euch murat gleich zeigen wie man da
hinten die böden pflegt und wir nehmen
euch heute jetzt einfach mal so mit das
ist schon komisch so in den schatten zu
stellen sehr witzig und ist gerade
eingeschlafen
hast du gehört ich fühle mich weiter
machen ja mit den wohngruppen und ich
mach die holzmöbel oder euch wie alles
da oder wie hat er ab harte arbeit
teamwork wünsche nicht erkannt werden
ok vorsicht wir haben hier unsere nicht
überdachte fläche also hier ist unser
esstisch mit den stühlen und wir haben
auch das überdachte fläche unsere lounge
und wir haben an beiden stellen
holzmöbel weil wir uns einfach für die
natürlichkeit entschieden haben und vor
allem ist es her unser haus unser garten
wir bleiben hier auch das heißt wir
haben wirklich qualitativ hochwertige
möbel hier gekauft weil wir zum einen
nachhaltig denken und zum anderen
wollten wir einfach keine
kunststoffmöbel die bleichen aus und
irgendwann ging es einfach schneller
kaputt holzmöbel muss man aber natürlich
pflegen wir jetzt welche aus teakholz
und teakholz wird ja auch im schiffsbau
verwendet das heißt es hält wirklich
feuchtigkeit aus daher musste ich hier
den esstisch und die stühle auch gar
nicht im winter weg stellen die waren
hier einfach gestanden ohne abdeckung
auch ganz wichtig wenn man es abdeckt
geben sie nämlich hier kaputt und die
möbel hier unter der überdachung dies
sind sogar gar nicht vergleicht also
hier wollten wir tatsächlich dass der
tisch so ein bisschen älter aussieht und
die da unten die haben noch ihre
natürliche holzfarbe trotzdem muss ich
sie jetzt natürlich pflegen das heißt
sie werden jetzt einmal abgeschliffen
und eben dann auch eingeölt damit sie
einfach länger halten und so können wir
wirklich dafür sorgen dass unsere möbel
hoffentlich eine ganze weile halten ist
wie weit der ehemann muss dann ehemann
ja auch pflegen sich darum kümmern
bisschen schleifen und allein hören sie
zu grad
ich glaube nicht dass du dich
beschwerden kannst ja ich merke gerade
durch fliegst des rollins kurz
mein werkzeug du kannst auch also hier
sieht man schon ist ein richtig schöner
holztisch aber natürlich hat der durch
die ganzen grill events ihr und das
essen und das basteln und backen und
verzieren natürlich auch einige flecken
bekommen wir hier ein paar fettflecken
oder natürlich auch weil er eben unter
freiem himmel steht kommt natürlich auch
mal vogelkot drauf und macht flecken und
deswegen möchte ich den tisch ist
einfach ein bisschen abschleifen
ich habe jetzt hier 150er schleifpapier
also so mittel find ich mache die c max
center schleifer als schneller geht aber
man kann die holzmöbel natürlich auch
mit der hand abreiben abschleifen dauert
hat nur ein bisschen länger in dort
würde ich empfehlen mundschutz zu tragen
eben wegen dem feinstaub gleich aber
outlook jetzt eigentlich auch ganz gut
ohne das mache ich jetzt hier mache auch
die armlehnen an den stühlen und dann
gleich noch da drüben die terrassenmöbel
dort haben wir einige wasserflecken weil
der murat einem hochdruckreiniger immer
mal schön die terrasse reinigt und die
möbel dann halt nicht weg stellt ist
nicht schlimmer wird's auch nicht sehen
weil eben gleich polster noch
draufkommen
aber ich schweife die auch kurz ab kann
sie ein öl- und dann sind sie wieder
fertig und bereit für den sommer
[Musik]
und während ich mich jetzt hier um die
möbel kümmern sagte murat euch wie er
sich um den holzboden kümmert
[Musik]
so war die terrasse aufräumt mache ich
mich mal im nutzgarten zu schaffen das
ist hier unser nutzgarten und hier sind
die ganzen hochbeete und jetzt geht es
ja eigentlich einfach um das get ready
versammlung oder gateway frühling wie
auch immer wir es nennen wollt diese
holzboden ist jetzt ein jahr alt und
ganz am anfang sah er aus wie unsere
wand da vorne und durch ein jahr bis die
ganze verwitterung das ganze wasser
durch die sonne gerade auf dem boden
bereich weil da wasser auf liegen bleibt
vertrautes holz sie sind natürliche
patina und so ein holz muss mich nicht
kümmern die kids laufen barfuß herum ich
lauf hier barfuß herum und nach einem
jahr sind im holzboden ungefähr so aus
jetzt hier zum beispiel wie gesagt man
muss man mal anschauen wo im holz solche
speisen rausschauen damit nicht die füße
reinkriegt und es muss man abschneiden
wenn man es richtig macht ein bisschen
kuhn parkett schleifer den leiten sich
irgendwo ausmacht einmal komplett mit
dem parkett schleifen geht man darüber
im ersten jahr bist du nicht machen im
zweiten jahr weil es ja auch geld kostet
im zweiten jahr wirklich zu machen
am ersten jahr wenn man solche flecken
hier sieht wie hier zum beispiel dann
würde ich einfach hier ein schleifgerät
nehmen und mit diesem schleifgerät
einfach mal über diese stelle drüber
das ist ja alles weg ist
[Musik]
und jetzt ist nämlich auch die pflege
gefragt pflege heißt für mich den ganzen
boden richtig schön sauber machen das
wäre jetzt abbrechen und nach dem abt
kärchern noch mal schön mit coolen
leinöl drüber damit das holz wieder
leben bekommt ein bisschen öl bekommt
und dann passiert es auch nicht dass es
holz wenn es mal trocken wird in einem
heißen sommer
dass es spricht dass es spröde wird und
es ist ganz ganz wichtig und das machen
wir jetzt alles unterzeichnet bar coole
tricks und vor allem was wir nicht
machen sollte wenn ihr so ein holzboden
bearbeitet nicht pur mit dem
hochdruckreiniger dafür gibt es extra
aufsätze
wenn es nämlich wirklich zum
hochdruckreiniger macht dann schießt sie
hier das ganze holz weg hierher
das habe ich nämlich schon gemacht um
euch das mal zu zeigen gerade an dieser
platte hier das schleife jetzt gleich
nochmal drüber
aber das passiert wenn er mit 160 grad
mit 160 bar ans holz hingeht dann
schießt ihr die ganzen fasern weg das
ist nicht gut das heißt dann wird es
extra vorsätzlich und fordert zeigt euch
mal jetzt und jetzt machen wir folgendes
wir koppeln hier
dieses teil hier ab und haben hierzu
diese holz bürste so sieht's aus ohne
die bürste
so liegen muss und jetzt schön rüber
fahren
ihr seht sich ihr seht auch wie sich
schon leicht löst der ganze schmarrn
[Musik]
es hat super funktioniert der boden sich
schon ganz anders aus ist ganz grau ist
weg jetzt so leicht silber geworden und
jetzt gehe ich wenn es trocken ist die
ich noch mal mit öl drüber das zeigen
auch noch ganz kurz und dann ist der
boden sicher safe sie cool aus und
erhält eine lange zeit so was ich auch
machen kann das ist auch eine coole
geschichte das benutze ich normalerweise
chris auto und zwar ist diese plötzlich
habe einmal diese gruppe ist eine feine
bürste und mit dieser grob bürste ist
auch richtig cool ich kann mich jetzt
drauf gemacht
jetzt stelle ich wieder ein ok etwas
mittlere stufe so jetzt kann ich doch
hier wie normalerweise machen beim auto
[Musik]
und radwegen im wasser verbrauche ich
ganz ganz wichtig wir wenn wir unsere
alten - schon gesehen habt das was ich
verwende ich komplett regenwasser wir
haben eine riesengroße 20.000 liter
große zisterne und daher regenmassen
drin
das heißt das ganze wasser was ich
benutze kommt direkt aus meiner zisterne
und deswegen kostet mich jetzt auch
nichts dass ich wieder die schwaben
wir haben da drauf
[Musik]
damit wäre heute noch fertig werden dass
ich hier volkan weitermachen und ich
kann jetzt schon mal starke männer noch
holen kann ist auch stark aber du kannst
hier weitermachen und nicht nur noch ein
paar starke männer und sind sie schwer
zu tragen und dann wird er nämlich
eingeölt und das macht ihr am besten
wirklich nicht hier auf den fliesen oder
auf euren via platten sondern auf dem
rasen
damit das öl nicht auf eure vielen
tropft und keine hässlichen spuren und
flecken hinterlässt ok morath für zwei
schaffen das nicht wir helfen und ich
habe ja komisch roller jo die schwarze
serie alleine geschafft bin ich wenn ich
nicht ein tennisarm hätte weiter weiter
weiter es ist ja nicht gestartet sei
[Musik]
wahnsinnig schwer
und wie kam das
[Musik]
st
danke papa okay die möbel sind jetzt
fertig geschliffen ich habs jetzt mit
dem team mit unseren freunden einfach
auf den rasen gestellt ich kann jetzt
hier nämlich erst mal grund putz machen
das heißt für mich saugen alles an groß
muss hier erstmal weg machen
das mache ich jetzt hier einfach mit
unserem aufs auge das ist so nass und
trockensauger und auch gebläse das heißt
man kann auch schön das auto damit mal
auspusten oder laub wegblasen und
wegpusten und ja erstmal den schmutz weg
und dann geht es hier schon direkt an
grünspan also da machen wir dann
wirklich die terrasse richtig schön
blitzeblank da alles ziemlich schmutzig
geworden
[Musik]
so jetzt immer hier mit dass amira
zusammen am tisch wo die mama schon
abgeschlossen hat und jetzt wäre das
natürlich bearbeiten dass sie steht
draußen jetzt brauchen natürlichen
schutz und dann immer hier
dieses filmes ist schneide 100 prozent
natürlich und das macht die samira jetzt
das ist rein biologisch brauche ich gar
keine sorgen machen mein schatz trotzdem
zieht die handschuhe waren habe ich
zweimal kann schon durch zwei linke hand
schulen sind warschau und gewinnen daher
mit zwei linke hände und deswegen diesen
seine handschuhe reich ok jetzt gehst du
ganz leicht drüber okay ist und dann
tust du hier über ok man kann es auch
natürlich besser ist es wenn man dem
tuch macht und zwar ganz normal
baumwolltuch nehmen und dann schön
einreiben das geht auch machte sich hier
ein schatz siehst du das einreiten dann
trotz auch nicht so das ist dann noch
besser aber das was du am besten kannst
okay ich will vielleicht nochmals tuch
nehmen weil sonst trotz zu arg wichtig
ganz ganz wichtig schon gefahren
hinweist wenn das tuch nachher komplett
mit leinöl getränkt ist bitte nicht
zusammen kleinen ecke werfen weil sonst
viele schreinerei abgebrannt weil das
kann sich dann entzünden also wirklich
wenn ihr so ein tuch benutzt mit leinöl
wenn ihr mit laien neue hantiert dieses
toben und gut zum lüften aufhängen und
jannik zusammenhalt in einer ecke ist
verstanden schatz sonst brennt die bude
ab und wir sind nicht versichert
ok alles klar also dann nimmst du das
wie gesagt so ein bisschen und dann
schön einmassieren ok alles war ja
[Musik]
so wären samira hier den das alles ein
öl die ganzen möbel und die sally
staubsaug tue ich hier nicht die stühle
ein bisschen abdampfen und hier gibt es
verschiedene möglichkeiten und zwar
einmal haben wir hier das ist hart es
oft
und dann gibt es noch den mix und erst
zum schluss lösen das ist dann wie so
ein wie so ein drehbuch
und wirklich erstmal alles wir abbrechen
[Musik]
perfekt
[Applaus]
wir haben richtige keramikplatten es
gibt auch wieder verschiedene arten
terrassenbeläge zu machen ihre vor
trüben gesehen ich habe da holz hier
habe ich keramik stein um bei den
steinplatten ist so wir haben uns dazu
entschieden
man kann ja fugen reinmachen und oftmals
sind kieselsteine drin bei den
kieselsteinchen das problem da wächst
irgendwann mal gras raus und das wollten
wir nicht deswegen haben wir hartz
reingemacht
trotzdem stützt diese harz nicht vor
grünspan so richtig grün sparen ist
sieht man auch hier in diesen ganzen
fugen hier und dem möchte man natürlich
rauskriegen das geht mit dieser bürste
nicht so gut es wird gehen mit pipi
mechanik druck wird es auch mit der
bürste gehen aber dafür gibt es extra
diesen terrassen reiniger damit auch ein
paar einen hochdruckreiniger
angeschlossen um mich wenig chemie kann
man hier einfach die terrasse nachher
einigen im hochdruck reihe
wie das geht zeigen euch jetzt gleich
ich kann doch noch was dazu sagen ja was
denn wir haben früher einer
stiftungsrats mehr im anderen stadtteil
gewohnt haben erste wohnung ja also ich
sage jetzt die straße ach doch karl
ebert straße da mir früher gewohnt und
wenn wir einem mehrfamilienhaus gewohnt
und mein papa hat er hat immer außerhalb
der arbeitszeit dann noch den
hausmeisterdienst gemacht und für uns
war das für uns kinder vor allem ein
kleiner bruder und ich wir waren so nah
zusammen aufzuwachsen die anderen drei
sind schon größer und für uns war die
kehrwoche immer so das highlight der
woche für uns absolut sind die kamera
dann fürs ganze hausgemachten zeitpunkt
ist ein wo es 220 familien als einwohner
und wir haben dann draußen immer
gekeltert und übrigens ist die kehrwoche
ist es ist wirklich kein spaß man sagt
man es ist ein mythos dass ist im
schwabenland ist beim baden nicht so
hier aber im schwabenland was mir die so
ist es samstags wird gekichert da ist
nämlich die kehrwoche und deswegen ist
es ein heiligtum der dass sich uns war
freitag immer indoor also innen
treppenhaus geländer und so weiter das
habe ich meiner mama gemacht und
samstags war outdoor mein papa und da
ich mich immer draußen auf die große
kehrmaschine gesetzt auch die elbe große
erreicht bald wieder mehrere autos sogar
noch kleiner hat mich trotz der papa hat
dann immer schön sagt man es bei euch
auch gekämpft haben okay genug
sentimentalität genug center mit genug
ist sentimentalität
jetzt geht es bei uns war es technisch
und ich zeige auch was man falsch machen
kann weil das habe ich auch schon falsch
gemacht
ihr könnt nämlich auch mit einem
hochdruckreiniger auch einiges kaputt
machen und zwar sind falsch handhabt
halt immer diesen abstand beim
hochdruckreiniger von 20 bis 30
zentimeter kann nichts passieren
gerade bei diesen fugen ist es ganz
wichtig den fehler was ich schon gemacht
habe und zwar direkt einen
hochdruckreiniger drauf gegangen bevor
ich diese wirst noch nicht bestellt habe
und habe die fugen weggeschossen mit dem
hochdruckreiniger
da muss ich es wieder harz auffüllen das
heißt wenn ihr so so ungerecht ist
richtig cool weil es ist mittig eine
schonende art und weise und ich schieße
nicht die guten weg oder die steine die
kieselsteine was drin sind das könnte
machen wenn ihr waschbetonplatten habt
und da richtig mies drauf sitzt da ist
es völlig genommenen kinder auch machen
ist mir egal
aber hier bei diesen platten ganz
wichtig nimmt da denn diese würste
diesen bürstenaufsatz das ist wirklich
genial und hier sehen diesen grün sparen
und den wo sich jetzt weg bekommen das
bekomme ich denke mit der ganzen wusste
ja ich komme mir gerade vor wie war mal
wer da hämmert schon mal jetzt wie ich
mach das das ist nämlich eine einfache
arbeit macht schon immer was auf wenn
also heidi ist da dann gehe ich an ans
öl erzeugt so wie es geht ja okay ist
ganz einfach dann okay also wir wollen
jetzt die terrasse reinigen ohne viel
chemie dass ihr können auch im grünspan
entfernt mit einigen mitteln
reinigungsmitteln da gibt es überall
reiniger wie sand am meer aber wie
gesagt mit druck und ohne chemie
funktioniert eben auch so machen wir das
jetzt hier
ich wollte morath hören die leichte
arbeit machen wir mit jeder was
schwieriges machen nicht mit mir
ok also ich kann jetzt hier die terrasse
schön befeuchten
ich habe jetzt hier nämlich einmal
hirnen drücker da kommt dann schöner
strahl auch gerade für ecken und kanten
geeignet wo man eben nicht so gut dran
kommt und dann habe ich hier einen
drücker und dann rotiert das ganze und
ich kann wirklich schöne terrasse
reinigen ohne selber kraft aufwenden zu
müssen
und wie gesagt ohne reiniger ich fange
jetzt hinten an
am besten den mann von hinten nach vorne
so habt ihr zum einen den überblick und
er läuft nicht über diese obere terrasse
über die im lieferumfang war sogar ein
reiniger dabei für steiner als er jetzt
gerade hier fließen wenn man den
benutzen möchte kann man den einfach
hier reinklicken und auch eben
mitbenutzen ich probiert aber zuerst mal
und wenn ich ihn doch braucht also wir
sind erst den zweiten sommer hier das
heißt so starke verschmutzung haben wir
nicht aber ich bin trotzdem erschrocken
denn wenn man sich die fakten anschaut
dann echt schon viel grün sparen da
vielleicht geht es ohne aber vielleicht
brauche ich auch einfach ein bisschen
vom reiniger
[Musik]
[Applaus]
da vorne auf der terrasse da geht's ja
noch so mit der verschmutzung noch mal
wirklich nur mehr den grünspan hier
unten auf der terrasse weil es eben
überdachtes und kein regen drankommt
haben wir echt richtig starke
verschmutzungen und da würde ich mit
einer bürste schon ewig stehen zum
putzen und deswegen nehme ich hier auch
dem hochdruckreiniger weil es wirklich
viel einfacher geht und wirklich ohne
chemie geht
[Musik]
guck mal hier habe ich jetzt noch so
flecken auf der terrasse ein bisschen
rostflecken das ist einfach wenn wir mal
ein wechsel draußen vergessen und es
regnet und es fängt dann an zu rosten
dann gibts auch flecken auf der terrasse
gebe ich jetzt nicht weg gekriegt aber
da gibt es einen ganz einfachen trick
und zwar einfach etwas cola cola löst
nämlich auch bei autos bei felgen und
fahrrädern die rostflecken sollte man
daher vielleicht nicht trinken sondern
wirklich punkten benutzen und dann schön
rüber truppen
[Musik]
so nachdem ich den boden sauber gemacht
habe ich jetzt nach ich habe einfach so
eine rolle genommen hat ein bambus stil
gefunden im garten
wie heisst raul darf sei aber nicht
dumpf jetzt durch alles schön einen den
ganzen boden
[Musik]
jetzt ist die terrasse sauber jetzt ist
unsere möbel hier dran also wird die
regale damit ich auch wieder unsere
schöne sommer decke anbringen haben mach
jetzt alles hier mit unserem alles
reiniger den hab ich selber gemacht da
gibt es auch schon ein rezept auf einem
kanal zum einen richter gut und er macht
wirklich alles
[Musik]
weder so typisch männer machen immer nur
sauber was man sieht aber ihr müsst auch
mal die möbel umdrehen vor allem die
boden möbel also die lausch es hat
ziemlich am boden
und da hat sich im winter schon einiges
angesammelt da die renten von und hier
spinnen und
[Musik]
sommerschule gleich mit der post haben
ja
[Musik]
andersrum andere stufe die ablage okay
und bei mir ist die ecke hand gehen
weiter weiter weiter weiter
ich bin fuß so perfekt so weil hier
kommt jetzt die ecke und hier das kleine
licht die ecke
[Musik]
[Applaus]
jetzt wird im ganzen krems grafik als
millionen das ist kein krims krams
tischdekoration ach so ok und salafisten
blumen das sieht man kann hier
wüstenblume strom ist schöne blumen
wachsen wird doch die muss ich nun hier
zurückschneiden
[Musik]
so hat man sich gar nicht weil sie nicht
erkannt ich hab mit dem minibus
versteckt hat das team eingebaut
kannst du mal sagen dass im 21
jahrhundert noch räder gibt die sich
drehen
[Musik]
ok bis wohin unser standort sonne hier
standort sonne also die können wir
eigentlich auch hier was haben wir so
eine schöne bunte ecke okay ich habe
jetzt hier noch beim christa ein paar
blumen bestellt aus mauer und die werde
ich jetzt demnächst auch einen pflanzen
also ich lasse jetzt erstmal hier guckt
dann auch wie es mir gefällt zu vom
standort her aber ich finde pflanzen
machen die terrasse und dem balkon
einfach schön und gemütlich weil wir
haben hier einen schönen garten aber
wenn ich jetzt hier so schaue so die
pflanzen hier oder die andere säule oder
gerade hier habe ich lass dir jetzt
erstmal stehen denn heute kann ich nicht
mal einen pflanze nicht mit echt richtig
kaputt heute ist so ein paar assen
teppich der kann ruhig nass werden
er hat den ganzen sommer draußen bin ich
weg liegt aber schatz da fliegt noch
immer weg der flieg ich weg macht keine
sorgen ich stelle einfach im sonnen eine
sonnenliege darauf nein dann nicht mehr
weg nein da fliegt nicht weg ich glaube
fest dass eine picknickdecke für die
kids die sitzen hier echt voll gern im
sommer und spielen einfach drauf
deswegen legen wir auch schön guck mal
ist auch eine ganz besondere aloe vera
richtig schön und das sind alle veras
ohne blumen 3 hat sondern flüchtet dran
hat ist wirklich ganz besonders
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wer denn jetzt falsch auf die frisch
geputzte fließe und die kaputt geht die
geht nicht kaputt ist made in germany
das kann nicht gut gehen so jetzt aber
fertig und zwar hier
der terrassen boden glänzt wieder
grünspan ist weg alle fließen sind wir
dass sauber die hochbeete sind sauber
dahin und da hatte ich im winter schon
mein papa so ein bisschen was
weggeschnitten
und der papa schneide generell gerne
pflanzen zurück aber das wächst hier
alles wieder nachher zum frühjahr und
die deko steht jetzt auch wieder
es gibt noch ein paar pflanzen die wir
da noch rausstellen aber es kommt
vielleicht noch ein bisschen frost in
der nacht deswegen bleibe ich noch
vorsichtig auch der olivenbaum bleibt
erstmal mit beheizung wir haben so ab
nächster woche kann man den genau danone
und hier das ist auch jetzt als geölt
unterscheide sich halt das schöne
altholz das ist einfach schön sieht
einfach toll aus deswegen kein
kunststoff für unersetzlich
aber wir sehen ist auch ziemlich viel
arbeit denken wie man den spruch was du
mir sitzt was besitzt auch nicht so
meins mal die holzterrasse von der anja
dann gehen wir zur holzterrasse was ich
auch gemacht haben wir das wollen wir
auch behalten
[Musik]
doch mal wie schön die ist geweckt bei
mir direkt hier bin ich auch fertig
geworden ihr wissen noch wie es vorher
aussagen und nachher sieg
[Musik]
ich find holz einfach genial aber es hat
jetzt den ganzen tag weggenommen und es
ist eigentlich schon viel hingegen
hochdruckreiniger nicht gehabt dann wäre
es noch länger gedauert
wir können also greifen müssen und
nächstes jahr schauen wir uns einmal an
gleich wo sich komplett mit ein paar
ketzler kommt einmal drüber
kommt drauf an also wie gesagt da muss
man echt bock drauf haben ich würde noch
mal machen so beim nächsten videos mache
ich so ein cooles video ich habe den
teich ja letztes jahr angelegt und ich
habe noch keine fischerei gemacht weil
ich wo ich meine frau dies weckt so ich
habe auch keine fischer 1 gemacht weil
ich erst mal gucken wollte wieso ein
teich funktioniert wie alles was man
alles machen muss der teich ist auch
richtig schön sauber und jetzt diese
habe ich die fischereien machen das
heißt weniger einen coolen typ hat für
fische ich mich keine kois haben diesen
zu teuer ich bin normale fischer haben
vielleicht gesagt wissen kann keine
ahnung
auf jeder packung chips ab schreibt es
in die kommentare mit fischen und kann
man nicht leben an seinem einem teig
schwämmlein kann man nichts machen weil
da sind die fische drin wenn du das mit
jetzt von seiner tochter das kann zu
benutzen das ist schon cool cooler der
reichen hier ja so dafür brauche ich
wahrscheinlich drei reichen bauch weg na
ja ein hammer
du bist also der brauch ich denke der
reifen schon so gehen weiter und zeigt
was wir drüben gemacht haben hier kann
man gegen so jemand holzklotz mein gott
was gibt's nicht mehr mitlaufen und mein
auge tut weh ich habe ich habe mir zum
mit hummer mit einem lanz ins auge
reingeschoben ja wie war das video ist
fertig also dass videos ja auch gleich
fertig aber das garten der garten ist
endlich wieder sauber garten terrasse
und ich muss sagen ich bin fix und
fertig also ich freue mich einfach nur
noch auf eine warme dusche auf meinen
tee und aufs bett aber ich bin glücklich
dass wir es gemacht haben denn endlich
können wir wieder draußen
die polster sind wieder da so ein paar
kleinigkeiten müssen wir noch machen
die pflanzen werden wir noch einsetzen
also dann auch wieder die hochbeete
bepflanzen und da warten wir aber noch
ein zwei wochen oder bis das wetter
wieder schöner wird ja wohl heute war es
relativ frisch aber zum putzen perfekt
denn beim putzen jetzt einmal auch schön
war und jetzt kann man zumindest schon
mal die sonnenstunden draußen wieder
nutzen
ich hoffe euch hat das video gefallen
wenn ihr noch fragen habt dann schreibt
sie gerne in die kommentare
wie gesagt den frühjahrsputz gibt es
auch schon auf einem kanal reiniger
selber machen gibt es auf meinem kanal
also dieses jahr war wirklich 2020 das
sauberste ja er war
und ja dann freue ich mich auf euer
feedback
wir sehen uns ganz entweder wenn wir
unsere pflanzen einsetzen
genau und jetzt gleich zum arzt weil ich
glaub mir ich hab mir wie zu einer
pflanze ins auge gestochen
siehst du das ich sehe nichts mehr wer
bist du ich habe auch bereit ist
eröffnet ja hoffen jetzt viel spaß
gemacht hat gelernt
das stimmt nach computerchips
[Musik]